yo what's up man it's g herbal you
already know what it is
check me out on the bullet kev podcast
two five out now
yo it's the bullet cavs show special
guest in here the guy just dropped his
album man
what's up broski 25 is out yeah man
what's up what's going on kids i saw a
meme and it was a pentagram
made of air force ones and there was a
one black one in the middle one in the
middle
trying to say something
to get the album early yeah that was
some funny [ __ ]
like clean was dirty was all type of
[ __ ] how many pairs of air forces do you
own because there was the video you go
into the store and just buying like it
seemed like a
truckload of them oh no i just i just
threw like
probably like 200 pair out like that
because i only win once like probably
two 300 pair like
eight nine trash bags full of them
business like threw them
just why ain't throwing away actually i
told my assistant to just go get them
away
yeah i was about to say that that would
be uh that'd be socially irresponsible
for you to throw away some brand new air
force i gave them away actually i didn't
even throw them away i just
gave away like went oh you're one and
done on the forces
yeah yeah yeah for sure yeah but you
might a lot right now though i just
bought like 60 something could you wear
a pair like for like
two days straight though uh like if
you're like in grind mode recording like
running around
jogging or jogging or something like
that yeah but if i'm going out like with
a fit i want it one
how many pairs of air forces in your
life do you think you've purchased
i've been banned since i was like a kid
bro over over a thousand for sure hell
yeah i
probably would buy a thousand [ __ ] in a
couple years
that shit's crazy man maybe a few years
365 days yeah probably like
and then and and these are just strictly
all whites yeah big bro
they ran through a million and a bit
that's how dr dre is though dre's like
that
dre got his his uniform it's the black
tea the black pants and
he only wears air forces once yeah
forces yeah that's
uh um i know i didn't ran through a lot
though bro i've been wearing them since
since like a kid literally never dabbled
in the black forces though
yeah i know i used to wear black forces
too though
that was a time in your life though when
things might have been different right
i used to wear black ones i definitely
used to wear black
um talk about this new album man i think
uh you know
this is you've been through a lot in the
last 12 months it's been public
and i feel like this album is an
important one for you and your legacy
man how you feeling about it
i'm excited man you know i woke up and i
got my first number one album bro i feel
good man
i feel real good congrats thank you bro
25 yeah what made you want to go with
that
uh you know i turned 25 back in october
and you know it's just just life and
you know the position i'm in right now
is surreal bro cause i lost a lot
you know along the way a lot of course
people i love didn't see
25 years old like when i was i always be
saying like i just said it more than one
time
like when i was 18 17 years old and like
one of my older guys
like from the neighborhood to turn 25 we
just started calling him og like yeah
you og status now
which is crazy it's crazy it's hard to
see 25 you know what i'm saying where i
come from it's a real milestone
so for me to be 25 years old and and
accomplish so much and reach this much
level of success in my life and
to still be modest about it because i
know it's so much
[ __ ] out there that i still want to do
you know
i feel like uh just where i'm at and all
the emotions i went through recording
this project and just you know
beating so much [ __ ] like everything
every obstacle ever came my way in life
bro i just found a way to get through it
like
not complain or not want to give up or
you know what i'm saying like not wear
that [ __ ] publicly you feel i'm saying
i just i just deal with it you know what
i'm saying and i think when i turn
25 bro i'm like i'm like lying like it's
like a switch
just went off i just i just start
thinking different and everything like
literally as soon as i turned 25 i was
like
i ain't gonna say i changed but it was
like some images
made me think about everything
differently bro so yeah man i feel like
you know
amongst your peers like in you know at
least my perception from a fan's
perception it's like
you seem to have your head on your
shoulders real straight like
you know the last few years you really
don't hear your name and no
goofy [ __ ] you know what i'm saying like
and the same can't be said for a lot of
the guys who are around the same age
doing the same thing you know what i
mean so
kudos to you cause you i feel like
you've been on your grown man [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying
for sure i've always been mature you
know i'm saying i always hit a level
head
and you know thought about [ __ ] a little
differently you know i'm saying that i
take pride in that bro i ain't trying to
be known for no goofy
weirdo bozo especially in this industry
man
a lot of [ __ ] like that take place man
you know like
[ __ ] be having gimmicks and [ __ ] like
that and it just oh no it don't really
it don't work out bad yeah right bad for
him bro so it's like
i just be trying to focus on me i don't
chase nothing that's not
funny you know what i'm saying i'm not
trying to be like the next artist i'm
just trying to be
me bro like the best be i could be and i
win doing that like [ __ ] all that other
[ __ ] 100
um i feel like right now we're kind of
you know chicago's had so many waves of
of uh
success from the 90s till now obviously
twist twisted carmen kanye you know all
that then chance and
and vic mensa and then and chief keef
and all that was kind of going on around
the same time and you you were part of
a lot of the drill scene but i feel like
right now
between you dirk polo g like it feels
like
this has been the biggest that
chicago hip-hop has ever been like it
feels like it's crazy
it's a crazy thing to say no no no
obviously kanye
i'm not trying to take away from kanye
as being the biggest artist in the world
but i just mean when you look at the
landscape of who's the hottest
[ __ ] in hip-hop
right like it's a lot of chicago and
it's never really been like that
it's always been like one guy but it's
like
y'all really running [ __ ] up right now
in a way that's like not fair to a lot
of other regions
and what's dope is you and dirk just
y'all
evolution since you started it's been so
special to see
because you guys have grown as musicians
grown as rappers grown as
men you know what i'm saying and
the longevity there's something to be
said about that as well man no i've been
hearing that a lot though i'm not gonna
lie like you're not even the first
person to say that you know
just from the outside looking in maybe
it looked a little different yeah
i don't know i like what everybody doing
you know what i'm saying but it's just
something different about chicago but we
grind differently
you know you know it's not no quitting
us like and i always say that i'll be
telling people like
man you can't really like take none of
this [ __ ] personal in the industry when
you go through [ __ ] all the adversity
that come with this
we didn't mention juice world too yeah
of course r.i.p
brother man you know that's that's
that's a given like automatically you
know
but chicago just i feel like
we built for pressure we built for
pressure we don't really you know burst
under pressure
and those people who last the longest
especially in this industry because it's
going
you're going to be under pressure you
know what i'm saying so i think that's
what stand out the most to me about you
know
being from chicago and seeing other
chicago artists like succeed and [ __ ]
how's um you know obviously appear yours
dirk is
is having the best year of his life but
he's also faced a lot of personal losses
recently
um have you been in contact with him
recently oh yeah you know i'll reach out
to bro on a regular basis so you know
what i'm saying
especially um you know recently after
after the you know the the untimely past
nights
i reached out yeah yeah you know we
locked in how big of a loss do you think
just
you know to opposite sides of the
spectrum but losing juice world and then
losing
king vaughn within inside of 12 months
for the city man it's it's crazy no it's
different bro like we take a lot of
losses in chicago man i don't know
it's like maybe it's a dark cloud over
that [ __ ] or something that's why i
don't really
i i don't know like you you can't take
it personal though like
it's like i don't know something about
this shot i feel like when you do that
you fall under it you know what i'm
saying you got to like just
try to keep pushing you know like oh no
i'm not gonna say it's
a bad thing like going on in chicago i
never really i can't really speak bad
about chicago of course as much as i'd
be wanting to you know what i'm saying
but
i mean it's home man yeah yeah um you
recently gave nikki props for giving you
like one of your first biggest breaks
with the shyrack record you know the
beam me up scotty tape drop but like
sure
how how much did that kind of change
your world
initially when it happened cause her
fans are crazy people shout out to the
barbs you know what i'm saying
they're writers for real crazy crazy but
how did that initially happen like how
did she reach out give me the story
behind that shy rack record
man i was i probably was like 17 or
something this one i used to be just
thugging i wasn't really like chasing
music trying to make
a real career out this [ __ ] but you know
i had already made a name for myself as
far as like
lyrically and [ __ ] you know um
and [ __ ] i was in the studio bro like
four in the morning some [ __ ] like that
it was late as [ __ ] night
and she had um they reached out they had
called my manager at the time like yeah
you know uh it's nikki he's out you know
these sneaky people we want um we're
gonna hurry the slide we want her to
come
right from the la and do a record you
know we [ __ ] with him
and we were so high like it's four in
the morning we have a lean
right right we need all type of [ __ ] and
we ain't think it was for real we like
man
ain't no [ __ ] nicki hang up and that
ain't dumb people and
they called back like a couple days
later like man what the [ __ ] is y'all
alone y'all not trying to come out
and do this record like damn they for
real it's really them and she put me on
the plane immediately i came out there
like two three days
met up with a guy in the studio she told
me how much she [ __ ] with me and she
pulled the record up and i did that
[ __ ] right on the spot
that shit's legendary yeah that [ __ ] was
crazy did she bring you out at summer
jam in new york because i was i was on
the side of the stage
for sure that was like summer jam that
was 2015
2014 2014. meek was on that show yeah
i think drake was there drake everybody
yeah no i was there
that [ __ ] was special then i met wayne
for the first time wayne was there
yeah yeah young money had that [ __ ]
showed up for sure that [ __ ] was crazy
but that had to be insane coming out
as a kid summer jam stage bro hang on
lies so crazy i never it was like
surreal to me it ain't it didn't even
like hit me when it happened you know i
wish i was like
how i am now like real focused and like
confident because right it didn't hit me
like i didn't even really feel like i
was there bro like even being on the
stage
i couldn't even see all the fans i like
blacked out i was so damn nervous doing
some [ __ ]
i couldn't imagine you know i just came
out there and
did it real quick and didn't try to get
off the stage just as
quick as possible i ain't gonna lie to
you that's that's gotta be that's like
nerves
that's some bucket list [ __ ] man hey
interrupting the interview to tell you
about our good friends at odd socks now
as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying
ooh shout out to my bony ass knees um
listen go to oddssocksofficial.com they
got all the craziest socks
these are the outsiders you know what
i'm saying they got spongebob
they got cheech and chong listen
breaking bad
godfather whatever you need they got it
and now they have underwear that's right
you can get your odd socks underwear
the boxer briefs are the best underwear
that you could ever fit on your ass
trust me when i tell you
these are chucky draws what you know
about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword
bootleg kev at checkout and you'll save
20 off of
of your order underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
heaven check out save 20
um you have been you know what i pre
[ __ ] with you
you always tap in with the west coast
like you've worked with mozzie yeah
you work with burner yeah um
yg i mean we can go down the list what
is it about like guys like mazzy like
burner like you know where because these
are independent artists you know what
i'm saying a lot
a lot of guys um you know when you're
independent you're from i feel like
the west is kind of an afterthought a
lot in hip-hop unfortunately you know i
understand an independent grind because
i'm still independent i'm an independent
right well just so people know this new
album is independent yeah for sure man
you know shout out to my partners man
universal republic and grooves right um
but yeah you know i understand the
independent grind it's a grind
and with with me knowing that i try to
like
connect with as many artists as i can
you know what i'm saying
to expand my horizons what i'm saying uh
and whether they independent or not you
know i [ __ ] with mozzie though like
nah monkey's one of the coldest man yeah
one of my favorite rappers me and mazzy
locked in for sure that's my real dog
but i'll be trying to like connect with
our
artists because i feel like that's what
it's for but you got to build like
relationships first of all like you know
what i'm saying of course i don't really
just want to just jump on songs with
people and
[ __ ] with a [ __ ] like oh yeah i'ma jump
on this and [ __ ] with him cause it's hot
or [ __ ] with this cause i feel like
i'm hot at the moment like
i never really wanted to be one of the
artists that just got songs with a bunch
of [ __ ] that i don't [ __ ] with
i'm saying like right so that play a big
part in it too like if i [ __ ] with you
and your movement then right right it's
nothing like it is really imma pull up
to the studio
rock out pull up to your hood shoot the
video you pull up to my hood whatever
the cape
um how hard is it man you know without
getting into the details of your
situation but like having something like
that
out there and something like that kind
of floating over you how hard is it to
stay focused
and finish an album under those
circumstances because i've been in
similar situations where
if it just feels like a cloud over your
head or a cloud over you
know for sure because you don't know
what's gonna happen you're waiting for
this for you're just waiting for to see
what
i've been there you know what i'm saying
so i can only imagine how hard it is to
just put your head down and get to work
you know what i'm saying
it's tough man but um like i said bro
i've been under pressure my whole life
so i'll be feeling like i'm built for
this [ __ ] bro
it is what it is i don't really like be
tripping over [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying like
i know i'm cool so at the end of the day
i just wake up every day and just
do the next best thing for me bro i get
up go to work it is what it is you feel
i'm saying like i don't really
i don't feel like one situation or
that situation in particular would have
been under pressure you know what i'm
saying like
i'm gonna just get up and do the right
thing has there been times where you
think
if you find yourself thinking about it
too much that it kind of puts you in
like a like a weird funk or depression
no i really don't i ain't gonna lie
that's that's that's one thing that's
that i i mean it's like a strength i
don't dwell on [ __ ] bro i don't
think about that [ __ ] i'm not yeah
waking up stressing over
like [ __ ] like that i got too much [ __ ]
going on in my life and already other
[ __ ] well
i mean plus you you just had a [ __ ]
baby too yeah so i don't really be
tripping off [ __ ] bro to be honest bro i
don't dwell on situations you know what
i'm saying
it's child number three for you right
two two child number two boys right
right
two boys first one with your girl yeah
one with
ariana yeah and tony yep yeah yeah um
how how's how has it been the second go
round now that you've already been
through it once because i know having a
kid is crazy no i mean
i don't know i love kids so it's it's
[ __ ] it's just
easy it's regular yeah you know what i'm
saying this i just wake the only thing
is [ __ ] we got a brand new baby you
learning the baby again that's the only
[ __ ] like
you got to clean the diapers yeah i mean
that's easy that's the easy right
really like comforting them you know
hardest part is to get the kid on a
sleeping schedule
yeah that's what i'm saying like yeah
just the comfortability of it you know
you got to really learn your kid again
what he like
what put him to sleep you know what i'm
saying how you need to rock him to sleep
and how many hours of sleep to get and
then you gotta sleep when he sleeps so
you can get some sleep your family
that's the only thing that you got to
really like adjust to everything else
that [ __ ]
be simple like is it how how because you
know having
uh two baby mamas and having two kids
who are very much so in your life
does everyone get along all the time
yeah for the most part because i feel
like you and ari have like been
extremely cordial at least
like you know it's smooth bro it's
smooth because a lot of times it's the
other way you know what i'm saying like
if i feel like that that
speaks a lot to what i was saying
earlier like you're just a real mature
[ __ ] you ain't gonna
smooth though i ain't gonna lie should
be smooth with me bro i won't be
tripping oh [ __ ] but nobody really like
be tripping how you feeling um about
about the finals man
my phoenix sons made the finest man i
[ __ ] with it bro
i'm happy for book and for chris paul
bro for sure i'm definitely happy for
both of them man
if they play the bucks that's not far
from chicago no it's not i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go to a finals game anyway
i got to i want to go you got to go
watch chris paul win the ring because
he's going
[ __ ] [ __ ] with chris paul you know i
actually want i want to see him and book
when you know
um i [ __ ] honest too though man i
hate to see him out
you know you want to see him hurt
himself silver [ __ ] but all i know is if
if the hawks
do make for phoenix if the hawks make
the finals atlanta is going to be
[ __ ] upside down
for sure you know it's crazy i really
that's why i want to go to the finals
though i hope
i hope atlanta makes it so i have an
excuse to go to atl
i like trey young for sure if they if
the finals is in atlanta i'm definitely
going
for yeah for sure 100 yeah yeah that'd
be but you're going for the suns
officially
okay okay otherwise you're going for the
hawks yeah i want to see trey win too
don't hang on
i mean i'm i'm either way honestly like
you know what i'm saying like if
if if phoenix play atlanta in the finals
i don't even care who wins to be honest
that's beautiful
uh so on this album you got some dope
features obviously kid leroy is on here
gonna yeah 21 savage polo polo little
teacher i mean yeah
i don't know that shit's crazy um what's
your favorite record on this album man
um
my favorite record is uh
it's like a tab between cold world
which was recorded here ready set
studios exactly i recorded that here in
this building it's crazy
um cold world is like my favorite
probably and
i like uh mad max a lot that's my
favorite you know
because i don't know i'll be i'll be
like i like that hard
lyrical [ __ ] right right right that'd be
my favorite [ __ ]
lyrically who is out right now that like
you're a fan of that you haven't worked
with yet because there's so much like
lyricism as an all-time high right now
uh i want to work with conway i like
conway a lot
hold on man he was just here recording
like two hours ago
i just talked to him oh you just talked
he literally was like yo tell him i said
what up we gotta work
then i just i was just on facetime with
him yesterday so okay okay okay
yeah he was just here yeah that's my boy
um
who else i'll [ __ ] with lyrically that
really got it that i
haven't worked with yet um
that's a lot it's it's it's a it's a few
[ __ ] it's really spinning
i always say conway probably the one
person that that's really really hard
conway coming and he comes with the pain
too for sure i feel like we both gonna
be like
like a two-headed dragon on some [ __ ]
you know i'm saying have you ever worked
with freddie gibbs yet
uh matter of fact i was just i was just
with freddie yeah me and freddie got
some [ __ ] i was just
with him like two three days ago freddie
gibbs he's a beast yeah
so you got some [ __ ] on the job i
actually jumped on somebody else [ __ ]
and freddy was on that you know what i'm
saying
there it is so conway g herbal record is
on the way yeah
no for sure for sure that'd be crazy
yeah i can't wait and
benny my man's man benny been locked in
for like a long time
i didn't went out there personally to go
[ __ ] with benny when like
in buffalo 60 years ago yeah oh yeah
buffalo is a crazy place no benny my man
we just were out there like uh when we
were out there april
yeah we was out buffalo in april and
that [ __ ] was
i ain't gonna i [ __ ] with the whole
gazelle to for real though like for sure
west side gun
all this [ __ ] to me like i want to work
with bro hang on no need to just go
let's go yeah just go lock it with all
three of them yeah why not hey if you
could do a joint album with anybody
right now who would it be
um a joint album with anybody
uh i think i ain't gonna lie to be
honest i'm working on some joint albums
already wow me and grizzly been locked
in
do some [ __ ] me and grizzly got some
crazy [ __ ]
uh i want to do a joint with polo me and
polo probably do a joint
um man baby's still gonna do our joint
album but if i had to just reach for the
stars man i would
say i want to do some [ __ ] with [ __ ] i'm
going big i want to do something with
whole i mean oh yeah that'd be great two
three four
five songs oh real quick why not hey how
many records do i so you got a whole
project with t grizzly
who's incredible yeah yeah yeah yeah t
grizzly been we've been in the studio
locked in
how many records you guys got so right
now we got uh like five
and the polo g herbo project is is that
something that's actually being worked
on no we me and polo got a lot of
records too though but it ain't even
like it's just a thought for real though
but i think it it might
you know [ __ ] might happen that'd be
crazy and then
what is this like we always hear bibis
is not rapping anymore
you know baby man you know he said he's
one of the
most popping executives in the videos
now i'm going to say on some mogul [ __ ]
right now
he's on his mogul [ __ ] we could use
another free crack though you know yeah
he definitely i want to drag him out
retirement man you know i think he
he gonna he gonna rap though he's gonna
put some [ __ ] out for sure because he
still loves music bro people don't even
understand like
the mogul [ __ ] he's on because he he
don't the thing i like about what baby
and what he's been doing the last few
years
is like he ain't like bragging about all
the
[ __ ] he's involved no he don't you don't
at all you know he let his work do the
talking for
him you know what i'm saying that's the
way he posted he always been a humble
[ __ ] anyway he's not really feeling
like
popping [ __ ] for real like he just be
chilling you know like if you know him
you know what he got going on you know
i'm saying
um and i don't think people really
realize like bro
really hard as [ __ ] it's not [ __ ] out
here that really could rap better than
him he'd just be chilling
i remember seeing him on tour he opened
up for ty dolla sign in like 2000 yeah
i remember 15 16. i saw him in austin
texas i was like oh this dude's
different
yeah no for real i remember that for
sure yeah yeah you know bro
he's still like one of the hardest
[ __ ] out right now that he's just not
rapping
are you are you um now that everything's
back open i know you're
you're you're doing some of the rolling
lines i know you're not doing miami yeah
no i'm doing are you doing la i think
i'm doing la
yeah l.a are you going to be doing any
tour [ __ ] are you just doing
spot dates no actually i'm i'm just
trying to figure out my routes right now
for tour you know we ain't really
i got a couple spot dates on the
calendar but i'm ready i'm ready to get
on tour bro
yeah i feel like it's overdue bro you
know she got delayed yeah got delayed
12 shows in and she was lit so i'm
definitely ready to pick back up for
sure we should be we're going to be
touring
we'll be touring sometime soon right
brick for sure
as long as you bring brittany on the
road with you oh yeah she go
i go man she makes sure it's all right
yes well look hey the album is out
um do we have a single that we can
introduce brittany what's the single
t-o-p t-o-p all right i'm gonna let you
introduce this
one savage let's get it